[Applause]
i know i haven't been home for a while
you are in our lovely home in mexico and
i'm here
in the u.s fighting for our future
you're probably watering the roses
taking care of the peaches
and making sure your turtles are well
fed
that's one of the things i miss the most
about home spending time with the
flowers
while you tell me stories about your
childhood
as you know we have been living in new
york city since 2015.
but life has completely changed over the
past year
at first new york city was about museums
and parks and school and friends
now it serves as a web that connects me
with all the other people who are
organizing to save the planet
you know how it started for me it was
that
and his wisdom everything you taught him
he went and taught the world all of his
words
about the responsibility that we have as
humans
to live in balance with nature were
passed down to me
i noticed the universal disconnect to
our planet
and remembered what you once told me
leave
everything better than you found it
i know you were talking about the dishes
but of course that applies to the planet
as well
i didn't know what to do at first the
world is so
big and it has so many bad habits i
didn't know how a 15 year old was
supposed to change anything
but i had to try to put this philosophy
into practice
i joined the environmental club at my
high school however
i noticed that my classmates were
talking about recycling
and watching movies about the ocean it
was a view of environmentalism
that was so catered towards an
ineffective way of climate activism
one that blames the consumer for the
climate crisis
and preaches that temperatures are going
up because we
forgot to bring a reusable back to the
store
you taught me that taking care of mother
earth
is about every decision that we make as
a collective
i am happy to tell you abuelita that i
changed everybody's mind in that club
instead of talking about recycling we
started to write letters to our
politicians
to ban soft plastic all together and
then
the unexpected happened we started
striking from school
i know you've probably seen it on the
news and maybe it's not that special
anymore
but at the time it was a huge deal
abuelita
imagine kids not going to school because
we want people to save the world
for the first global climate strike
which was called on by
greta tinberg i got 600 of my classmates
to walk out with me
greta timber is a teenager who first
started striking for climate
her boldness inspired me and i was
shocked
by the realization that youth could turn
public opinion
on social issues the movement exploded
and i became one of the main organizers
for new york
the us and the world
i started speaking up about climate
justice and indigenous rights
and intergenerational cooperation
that was only the beginning though the
busiest week of my life will forever be
the week of september 20 2019.
me and my friends got 300 000 people
to strike for climate in new york i wish
you could have been there
we walked through wall street demanding
climate justice
that same month i went to the united
nations climate summit
i spoke on a panel with al gore
i met jay inslee and naomi klein and
built my gibbon
and the president of the united nations
it was the most amazing week of my life
because everyone i knew
came together all my teachers all my
classmates
and even some of my favorite stores
closed down
to strike for climate if you had asked
me why i did all of that
my only answer would be how could i not
it's been one year since it all started
for me
and it gets a little tiring at times but
if there is
one thing that you taught me is
resilience
i remember that you went to mexico city
every day for 30 years
to get money for the family and i know
that aguelito
has been going out for 20 years to
protect sacred land from big companies
that want to take it
a year is nothing compared to the
struggles that our family has been
through
and if our struggles make the world a
better place
they will make us better people there
have been some hardships abuelita
out there in the world people expect us
kids
to know everything or at least they want
us to
they ask questions and i give answers as
if i really knew how the world works
they want hope and we give it
i have organized written spoken
and read about climate and policy almost
every day for the past
year and i'm just a little worried
that i won't be able to do enough
abuelita
for me being 18 years old and trying to
save the world
means being a climate activist before
maybe it meant studying to be a doctor
or a politician or a researcher but i
can't wait to grow up and become one of
those things
the planet is suffering and we don't
have the luxury of time anymore
saving the world as a teenager means
being good with words
understanding the science behind the
climate crisis bringing a unique
perspective into the issue to stand out
and forgetting about almost everything
else
but sometimes i want to care about other
things again
i want to be able to sing and dance and
do gymnastics
i truly feel that if all of us took care
of the earth
as a practice as a culture
none of us would have to be full-time
climate activists
when businesses turn sustainable when
the power grid runs on renewable energy
when the school curriculum teaches us
that taking care of the earth is part of
our humanity
maybe i can do gymnastics once again
don't you think so abuelita
we can do this all i'm trying to do with
my work is give that optimistic mindset
to other people
but it's been a little hard there's
greed
there's pride there's money and there's
materialism
people make it so easy for me to talk to
them
but they make it so hard for me to teach
them
i want them to have the confidence to
always do their best
i want them to have the heart and the
courage to love the world
just like you taught me i wrote this
letter to thank you
thank you for inviting me to love the
world since the moment i was born
thank you for laughing at everything
thank you for teaching me
that hope and optimism are the most
powerful
tools we have to tackle any problem
i do this work because you showed me
that resilience love and knowledge are
enough to make a difference
i want to go back to mexico and visit
you i want to show you the pictures of
the things that i have done
i want to show you the climate
legislation that we've been able to pass
i want to smell the flowers and fight
for climate justice alongside you
take it i love you shia
[Music]
you